karen muhlhauser puede ver el techo del
tribunal supremo de eeuu desde las
ventanas de su apartamento en washington
dice
hace casi 60 años abortó sola y en
secreto
ahora con 80 años no se imaginan los
derechos de la mujer regresando a esos
días oscuros
estuve buscando fotos pero no pude
encontrar ninguna de cuando hice esa
tontería
una vez en college park en el quinto
sexto y four
cuando estaba en la universidad allá en
1964 vivía con mi novio y quedé
embarazada un embarazo no planificado mi
auto indígeno aborto y es sorprendente
que esté aquí
hasta ahora gpn exceso de sal frente
zinc
ay
pensé que había tenido éxito con la auto
inducción y me estaba preparando para
subir a un autobús para volver a la
universidad pero me desmayé en el suelo
de la terminal de autobuses y me
desperté en la oficina con un charco de
sangre y creo que había cuatro o cinco
personas allí y debían saber lo que me
había pasado pero no me ofrecieron
ninguna ayuda me dejaron cambiarme de
ropa e irme
michaels
en mí
no solo culpa el tribunal supremo de lo
que puede ocurrir con los derechos
reproductivos en eeuu también señala a
las generaciones más jóvenes
y
me sorprende porque cuando cumplí 18
años voté pero los jóvenes de este país
son los que menos votan quizás el 20 por
ciento de los jóvenes con derecho a voto
votan
así que creo que llegar a los jóvenes
para los que el aborto ha sido legal
toda su vida les resulta difícil de
imaginar porque la mayoría de ellos
apoyan el derecho al aborto
hauser ha sido una activista de los
derechos de la mujer durante casi seis
décadas y promete pasar el resto de su
vida luchando para defender esos
derechos fundamentales